[Music]
giant boxing fan
he sends me this text message he goes
dude check this [ __ ] out
and it's you training with rafael
cordero
and i remember looking and going oh [ __ ]
what
happened what happened because the last
time you were in here
you were talking about how you didn't
want to work out yeah because it would
ignite the ego hey let's talk about that
too
so um i was discussing my wife something
about me being away you know when you
have to
you sometimes want to complain on your
wife you want to take care of the hands
some kind of
perspective and she said well why don't
you just get on this
um treadmill for 15 minutes a day i
thought she said just 15 minutes so it
went from 15 minutes a day to 2 hours a
day
and um that's what you were worried
about
yeah exactly um but i was complaining
about my weight
and so um i don't know
i guess i tried on some clothing it was
disastrous and so i was worried about my
weight
and she told me the 15 minute round it
went two hours a day
and um i just started losing weight and
then um
somebody my brother-in-law said hey mike
man i know you're not gonna win but
somebody said would you fight this guy
for like
40 million or 30 million bucks i said
man get that whoa
i said oh that's not the thing
i said whoa and i said like well who
would they like me to fight
and say one minute and they go then it's
bob sat but
okay and so i'm saying to myself well i
know bob
and i said no because i know bob is big
and strong i said ho
one minute how would they like me to
fight him can i fight him under the
markets of queensberry rules
and he said one minute mike he asked the
guy the guy said yes i said i'll fight
him
right and so bob sapp was the first one
that was brought up
yeah and though for people who don't
know bob stop bob sabb was a
giant fighter and pride at one time he
was like 375 pounds he was fighting all
the kickboxers solid muscle
with abs that's incredible right and um
it went from him to somebody else and
another guy and an mma than this guy
and then somehow you know some other
fighters vanda then it went from
who else it was another heavyweight
champ it was just a bunch of guys up
here and fight
and they say you know it came down to
roy
how did and i'm like i don't know what
the hell is going on and then
he signed the contract i signed the
contract next thing you know i'm in the
gym again
and it's disastrous i'm trying to get in
the [ __ ] i painted them i did i really
do this [ __ ]
you know you you would probably know
because if you getting in shape and
getting conditioned they're two
different
animals they don't even belong in the
same
workout division of working out like
getting in shape is just being kind of
fit yes
you know that's getting in shape being
able just to fit your clothes being in
condition
is being able to come outside of your
soul
and you can't do that automatically
you're talking about being in fighting
conditions yes yeah
yeah that's a rare state and you can't
keep it for very long
no it is just people need to understand
that right the emotional state to
prepare for that
is oh mind boggling well that's what i
was seeing when i was seeing you hit the
pads i'm like this isn't just working
out
there was something going on man when
you were working out with cardero and
you ripping to the body and throwing
those hooks
i was like this is a man who's preparing
to go to combat this is not
normal getting ready to work out [ __ ]
that's why when i saw that video i was
like oh let me tell you something about
that video
yeah i did that video and i was in bed
for a week
that was 30 seconds and i was in bed for
a week
and it's not funny because it made me
realize that this is this is this is
big [ __ ] okay big boy this big boy [ __ ]
you were that is right there yeah
that wasn't really cool that's in the
gym that's now
the thing is though now that's now
that's that's going for
you know five and six rounds that's now
but i'm talking about before that 30
seconds
the first time i ever did it i i i
caught um
what's the [ __ ] you killed when you
can't wait everything came in everything
all that [ __ ] they came back that made
me quit boxing all the pain started
coming back
so when you started training again did
you start doing it slowly after that
extremely slowly
and then i started um dabbing and
alternative stuff
like what kind of stuff cryotherapy type
[ __ ]
cryo um stem cell research and
therapy and some other interesting stuff
that i just don't know
and it's just beautiful stuff like what
kind of stuff
i don't know hyperbaric chambers and yes
everything
everything everything to help you
recover it's really interesting
it is it well i saw you when you walked
in today i was like god damn you look
good
you look good dude like your muscles
look good you look like you're
vascular you look fit and that's um
and i'm starting to feel fit that's
what's interesting so i know what they
do and stuff
like i think i'm in shape and then the
next thing you know
you think you're in shape and then you
start having like um ralphia start
throwing punches at me
it's like you're fighting i can't punch
back one i gotta avoid and then
two rounds go by and he said whoa i'm
not in shape i'm in the bag six rounds
i'm doing this three or five round six
and i'm jumping rope
and then i do two rounds of somebody is
a whole different psychological
preparation and
how much how much time has gone since
you first started exercising like when
did it when did it start
so here we are was like august 23rd or
something like that
22nd all right when did when did it
start
it had to start um
something like april april so much
something like
in the middle of the lockdown yeah so
you just
just started just training and now here
you are
five months later four months later
how how far away do you think you are to
being in like fighting [ __ ]
oh fighting [ __ ] when the time comes
like by um november 28th yeah that's
when you'll be ready
exactly now why did you guys decide to
move
you were supposed to be in september
right supposed to be there was a viewing
um situation um at the proper timing for
more people for audiences yeah that
nature
it's so exciting it's going to be
awesome because um
it's going to be um me and everyone else
that's involved arrows in anyone
innovation then we're going to start off
the legends only league and that's going
to be really
um breathtaking especially starting off
with me and roy yeah
and um i'm looking forward to that
because i have athletes from
every general it's an array of everybody
who was
who believes that someone they're all
going to come back in all fields
and this is going to be something that i
mean um the arrows
intervention created together and i
think this is going to be pretty awesome
so legends only league would be like all
sports baseball bats
tennis yeah i think imagine it's [ __ ]
crazy like we did what billy jean
king did have somebody yesterday one of
sabrina somebody played
mcenroe and that kind of stuff right
exhibitions and stuff like that
somebody like um a man of war can play
one-on-one with whoever i ever send to
somebody
yeah i mean men of peace men of wars the
horse
[Laughter]
meta world peace yeah yeah no it's it's
an
amazing idea but particularly for you
like seeing you hit the bag again
and seeing you hit the pads and get
excited about it is very
very interesting to me because uh i knew
that you had that thing in your head
where you didn't want to ignite your ego
and then you had this quote
that the gods of war reignited your ego
i
read that i got so excited well that's
the excuse i can use
you know that's a really great excuse
that i can use
but it's uh it was a great quote it made
me excited and i when i'm when i'm
seeing you training i mean
you know some people that you know
everybody has opinions
when something like this happens when a
man is 53 now you're 54 yeah 54
and decides to fight again as fit as you
look
like why not why not why not you could
do whatever you want why can't
if you can go bungee jumping and ride a
bull listen um
impossible is nothing to somebody that
tries
everything that someone said was
impossible has happened
yeah it's certainly well listen in 2020
with all the ways of recovering all the
things that we know limitations
create impossible well it's different
now limitations are different now
exactly so when you like that video when
you were ripping the pads and working
out with rafael cordeiro
how many like how long into that was
that like how how quickly did you get
your speed back was it right
right away was it right but that was our
first day that was your first day that
was our first thing this child
said that was our first day wow and
after that day i was in the bed i had to
come get the guy
to do the [ __ ] shots and electrocute
me to get me back i had the sciatica hit
me i couldn't walk i was crying
to my wife and i was like wow
[Laughter]
and i don't know why um after that i
should have said this is over i'm not
gonna do it but um
that ego stuff hey come on please did it
does it do you feel like you felt in the
old days
like when i mean in terms of your mind
like the enthusiasm about this
enthusiasm yes um sometimes um
i feel like i say this is [ __ ] i
can't be feeling this good
you know and then um and um
i don't know i think i really am i'm
feeling good i said this bag
because i know the bag is a bigger bag
200 pounds and i said well this bag
wouldn't be moving like this
i'm not hitting it kind of decently you
know no you look good
there's look this is not like uh i've
seen guys come back
and you see them working out it looks
sad and it doesn't look good what's
exciting
about you coming back is how good you
look training
why not in this day and age just but
being a real fighter
this is what you know you see so many
people that's in the gym matter of fact
i've boxed people in the gym that kick
my ass every day but they know what's
different
when you get them in the ring and yeah
the light on them and people are eating
popcorn and drinking beer
and they freak out
you're mike tyson exactly you understand
that yeah i know
if anybody knows how to deal with that
pressure it's you absolutely but you
know you
it's good but if you don't have the
doubt you're going to have a lot of
trouble
right you have to have that doubt right
you have to have a little bit of that
yeah now is it this is a
this new phase of your life where all of
a sudden you reignite it and you want to
compete again this has got to be fun
it is fun but uh yeah it is fun i do say
it's fun but it's still um
it's apprehensive stuff yeah you know
it's apprehensive but it's still like
you said it
is fun but it seems so exciting like to
watch you train and get ready
it's like to me i'm like [ __ ] yeah like
what do you want a man to do
what do you want a man to just sit
around do nothing just wait
go for walks do whatever the [ __ ] you
want and if you could still do this the
way you're doing it
why not hey um
i don't understand it either but i want
to do it i don't understand i just want
to do it and
um i feel like i was born to do this
stuff
well you certainly were at one point in
time in your life but you had moved on
to a different chapter of your life you
had completely stopped doing that you
were doing a tyson ranch thing
smoking a lot of wheat you stopped
smoking weed totally much yeah
pretty much stopped it's gonna stop wow
wow that's that's a big
change but when you're right away
something like this is all about change
you know you listen you can't continue
being a comedian
if you're not sharpening your um your
psyche
up even when you're doing it right here
you're practicing your comedian
act you know you have to continue to
practice the more you practice it
and say if you practice it every four
year you'll be better
if you only practice it for a month so
the more you do it the better you become
do you feel like that now in this
comeback that like
you are only sort of scratching your
potential because
like you're just getting back into shape
again a year from now
you'll be even better shape and you'll
be more conditioned to do what you want
to do
like you're you're in this yeah yeah
you're in this
rebuilding stage now it's and now that's
exciting
yeah when you go to your um when you go
to your doctor these people who
have this alternative stuff and you see
the development you feel the healing
process and you say come on tell me this
why did this why is this happening to me
why not name it why a guy like me who
just got off drugs who just gave up his
life and don't care about nothing
he this is happening to him you know
since i married my wife all this good
stuff started happening and i'm saying
wow what is this stuff all about
whatever it's all about it's good i'm
like really grateful take my money
yeah that's what i said i said take my
money i want to watch it let's see it
and it's not about money because the
money's going to be in charity and
people want to
and it's just about doing something good
and not from that perspective
that could be i like feeling like i'm
doing something good for somebody more
than myself
that's a beautiful part of it yeah that
is going to go to charity but
it's also an exciting matchup and i'm
watching roy work out too and roy looks
fantastic
it's going to always look fantastic if
he was a little 100 pounds of boy he's
going to look good he just really looks
good
roy jones jr i mean that's one of the
things that makes this fight so exciting
is that uh
you know roy is like yourself one of the
all-time greats
and still looks physically fantastic
like you see him moving around hitting
the pads
his hand speed looks great you can't
train with anybody that looks like he'll
[ __ ] do that
right stuff well he always had such an
unusual style you know with
very few jabs he would throw left hooks
instead of jabs you know i mean roy
always had like one of the strangest
styles in all the boxes
it was strange but it was very effective
super effective
yeah very effective just incredibly hard
to prepare for too because try to find
someone who no one's going to do that
yeah
no one can emulate him in the gym now
when you
decided on uh a fight and decided an
opponent what were the
were there other i heard that someone
that offered you shannon the cannon
briggs for bare knuckle boxing no no it
was just um
tyson um the tyson fury
um was box sap types and fury and quite
other guys but
certain things just happened and it
didn't happen and then um
it was holyfield it was shannon with
some other guys
from mma and then roy turned out to be
the right guy i guess we did a survey
and
roy popped up the winner well it's
certainly a giant name
yeah yeah holyfield would be a great one
too but it's just having a guy like that
that has that big name
that is also an all-time great and that
also wants to do it too
and to get the public excited i mean i
think it's a perfect fight to get the
public exactly
so do you think that once you fight
roy that that'll be it or do you think
this is just going to be the beginning
of this new chapter in your life
i i believe this is just going to be the
beginning of whatever happens happens
in life this is pretty interesting being
on here talking to you and knowing that
um
the extent of the wavelength of people
are going to hear this stuff is pretty
interesting because this is now this
is true it's really going to no longer
in my head and
i'm stroking it it's real and it's like
wow
yeah it's wow yeah i can't wait man i
want to be there
i want to see it hey um down the street
here
i'll come back i didn't know i forgot
the name of the dignity center
mm-hmm that's where it's going to be
yeah yeah and is it going to be an
audience it can't be an audience yet i
don't believe
on again i believe only like i don't
know what what i'm going to say our
entourage
right a small amount of people yeah
family fight group
and this is going to be eight rounds i
believe so yeah
so how did you arrive on eight rounds
hey listen um
beat the hell out of me i wanted to do
the exhibition i wanted to help the
people i said why not
he [ __ ] around but now i'm getting in
condition and we're gonna do this stuff
well eight rounds gives you enough time
to work it gives people enough time to
get excited about it
um when when you think about uh an
eight-round fight
um do you fee see yourself moving into
ten rounds and 12 rounds in the future
and we don't know what the future holds
but we're looking forward to just having
fun and doing it for um
uh purpose reason because people were
talking about you literally fighting for
the title again hey i'm not interested
i'm misinterested in fighting for the
title of giving
okay okay so just doing this for good
so exciting for you but also generates a
lot of positivity exactly
yeah i love that and feels um soul
cleaning for some reason because you're
giving the way to charity that you're
doing something good you're doing it for
myself
this doesn't do it for me no more right
that makes sense
yeah that makes sense so it's both
things so you get to excite yourself
challenge yourself but the good is all
going to exactly
excellent i won't have in my mind i'm
getting paid i just don't want to never
have that in my mind again
yeah i don't want to have oh i'm getting
something
for what i'm doing kind of attitude
somebody said and this was kind of
hilarious someone said hey i heard that
they're just gonna
just mess around and that they're not
gonna go for the knockout i go do you
know who the [ __ ] you're talking about
i go you're talking about mike tyson and
roy jones jr
do you really believe that that two of
the all-time greats once they start
throwing hands that it could
it won't get crazy well of course it is
because both of us are who we are and
we're gonna
show our skills and nobody's gonna look
stupid and it's just gonna be
interesting i think yeah do you have any
other people in mind like do you have a
game plan in mind like after roy or
you're just thinking only about roy
right now
at this moment only roy but it's just
some interesting people that we have
that i'm gonna announce later
now there was some talk of you and roy
way back in the day when roy fought john
ruiz won the heavyweight title yes
yeah so what would what did you think
about that fight back then
i thought it was really interesting
because i couldn't use the money back
then
so um me and roy talked we were in texas
and we went to houston with the houston
we went to houston we talked and um
after we talked we just went out and
chilled out but um
it was interesting never happened so i
don't know what happened to me something
must have happened to me and
it just didn't happen that's one of
those things right there's always all
these potential fights
that don't quite line up do you have
other fights in your head that like were
potential fights that didn't line up
that you wish did
no everything happened for the reason
that is happening now
i'm excited about this fight i'm excited
about this fight stylistically too
because i always
i always liked that fight stylistically
i was so interesting
you know because you were just this
unstoppable force and roy was so fast
and so slick i guess i'm just prepared
to do a lot of running and chasing
yeah you know yeah i was that was real
difficult to get in condition for it
like
chasing this [ __ ] little guy so how
many days a week are you training now
every day every day you know i have the
sundays off and stuff
every day and what what is a a typical
day for mike tyson right now
all right the day starts
as soon as it's daylight from 5 30 out
through the four mile
run come back
what am i doing when i come back i'm
back i'm in the shower
from the shower i go downstairs i
let the birds out fly the birds come
back in
may do some um i have a machine where
you could do the twist
mm-hmm absolutely i have exercises yeah
and
i'll do that probably 200 times on both
sides
and um i just um grab a bite you know i
may have some
i'm eating meatless i may have some eggs
instead of not eating eggs you were a
vegan for a while right
how long were you vegan for a couple of
years for a couple years
when did it stop when did you stop doing
that
i don't know not too long ago so did you
stop because of the training or did you
stop before that
yeah this stop the reason because of the
training and it was yeah because of
what i wanted my body to look like and
the students that i wanted to possess
so you started eating meat red meat
everything no regular
only um elk and bison
oh red meat that's red meat yeah yeah
okay wild stuff
you're eating elk and bite too i want to
give you some of my oh yeah it really
would you please
[ __ ] you please 100 you kill it yes yeah
i would like for you to do that i'll
give you something from that elk right
there
that would be so awesome yeah i have
three commercial freezers in the back
i would love that i would love that yeah
like when i look at food i don't look at
food
like i used to look at it i look at it
for what it's for
yeah even what it's for to take care of
the body
exactly and well that's the best meat
you know i i realize that there's
you know things that are good for other
people like the the kale and the
vegetables and all this stuff the
blueberry and then for me it's really
poisonous
it's not that stuff's bad for you but
yeah that stuff's not good for my blood
type and my health conditions and all
that stuff
kale all that stuff okay kill me girl
yeah he's gonna kill me can't kill me
well no actually that really yeah
for me i'm careless toxic to my blood
and everything
so when you were a vegan what were you
eating oh man nothing
and then my wife called me the miserable
vegans that's not vegan isn't what
you're doing mike
just being miserable now i think it
comes down to um
when um and it's interesting that i've
done it when i was because i would
sometimes just overdo it sometimes like
sometimes i go
for religious fast for 30 days i might
overdo it sometimes i might not eat for
the whole day
instead of just for them daytime nights
for a couple days just not eat period
don't you think
but that's just your championship
mentality right like you're always
pushing yourself even when it comes to
something like fasting
like you know it's pushing it it has
something to do with suffering so
yeah i don't know what it is i can't put
my feelings on it's about how much how
long can i suffer more than this person
or that
person okay this person do what i did
right right right i remember you saying
that too about training that you would
get up in the morning and train
because you wanted an edge you wanted to
know that you were training while they
were asleep
exactly yeah i remember thinking that
back when i was doing martial arts i
remember reading that i'm like i want to
do that too
i copy a lot of [ __ ] you did well you
always have to have and if
and even if it's not suits so you have
to have
and that's where delusion comes in
because delusion is only delusional when
you don't accomplish the goals of making
your delusions a reality
right that's what it's delusional right
you you're just
enforcing your mindset oh yeah to allow
those delusions to be the reality of
your
um acceptance now when you're doing this
and you're getting up in the morning and
running
does this like do you feel like you
felt in the old days do you i mean i
don't mean physically i mean the mind
like you're
preparing for war again do you does this
does this like reignite those old
thoughts the way
you were when you were the champ the way
you were when you're on your way to the
title
like this is a this is a whole new way
of your life you know what's really
interesting
that sometimes um
periodic it's not real but sometimes i
struggle with the fact that while the
possibility i can really hurt somebody
like you don't want to hurt them
what do you mean but you struggle
struggle with the possibility that you
could hurt them
that is sometimes it's orgasmic
sometimes
yeah like some fights like particularly
like
tyro biggs or someone that you had
problems with
someone that you you had animosity
towards
so when you finally get your hands on
them hey um
what does it mean um when fighting gets
gets you erect what does that mean it's
a good question
means you're getting excited yeah so
that that's going through your mind
right now well that's how i get when i
was a kid and i
you know sometimes i get to twinkle the
twinkle
yeah well that's what i'm saying is like
you reached a state
as a human being as a champion as a
ferocious fighter
you reached a state of of ability and of
accomplishment that very few humans will
ever
ever touch and feel that's why i'm
asking you
when you're running when you're hitting
the bag when that heart's beating again
and
you know who you are you're mike
[ __ ] tyson
so when you're doing all this [ __ ] again
you're still mike tyson those thoughts
have got to be burning inside you again
it's gotta be pretty wild i don't know
it's um it's wild but um
i believe it's um it's rightfully so to
be that way and i just know how to
um i don't think i i'm master but i just
know how to deal with it
i don't let it overwhelm me no
well of course not but saying that
it gets you orgasmic that's a strange
thing to say
well that's just what i wanted to find
out because you're really bright
and i thought you were figuring no i'm
being very serious no i know
i i know you're being serious but i mean
no one will understand that
other than you like that's your your
mindset
like no one but i think that like all
the things we were talking about before
the way you drive yourself the way you
push yourself
the way you put yourself into that frame
of mind no one's gonna understand that
other than you
so no one's gonna understand you get an
erection from thinking about hurting
someone
more than you will you don't there has
to be fear based in somewhere
fear-based maybe or
um maybe just
maybe not fear-based but maybe embracing
the fact
that you're gonna go into this with
everything that you have the chaos of it
all
and and the ultimate goal is to hurt
somebody the ultimate goal is to be
extremely successful
the way you can be extremely successful
the thing you do great
is to crush people so to
have that encompass everything this
fighting is the only thing i don't ask
a lot for um i just don't ask him for
help for that
you don't ask him for help for fighting
yeah because you think you got it
no i just don't think i oh you don't
think you should ask i just don't want
to be involved with that kind of mindset
in our law
so i know you know people do they go to
i just don't i ask them because it's
just
i don't like the way i think and i don't
want god to be
you know involved with the way i think
at that time well this is what's so
interesting to me about you fighting
again because of the conversation that
we had the last time you were here that
you didn't want to reignite your ego
clearly your ego's blazing right now
i mean you're ready to go well maybe
because i um
i'm an addict a former addict and i'm on
a narcotic ring the camera's on me yeah
he's a big narcotic and maybe
right that has something to do it as
well but i like to think it's under
control until the night of the event
yeah the night of the event so it's the
the addiction will get purged with the
with the performance
yeah that's why i'm you know i was i was
doing um if you don't mind me to
interrupt for a second i was um
the book that talks to what they call it
audiobook and it was called
um the gene key okay
this book and the book was explaining
about why
that we are who we are in that
perspective that most of the people like
you and myself and people people just in
general
who is not at that level even anyone to
have a creative mind
is victimized to depression and the
reason is because um
when that created when that moment
whatever it is
that causes that creativity is not
fit the proper information that is
successful and that is
accepted in whatever space of the brain
and the mind that once
it wants to be accepted and it's not
accepted it
it crumbles does that make sense
well i feel like with someone like you
the highs that you reach
in competing the highs you reach in
fighting are so high
that it's probably very difficult to
it's probably very difficult to just
exist
outside of that and i know you love pot
for that reason because it calmed you
down and mellowed you out and chilled
you out abso
absolutely um it made me like myself
mm-hmm
do you understand that yeah i do yeah
it gives you forgiveness of yourself
yeah i agree with that i never thought
about that i never wanted to be
forgiving much because that's really
powerful stuff
yeah they have to accept forgiveness is
really and to forgive yourself
yeah yeah yeah it's hard to forgive
other people sometimes it's harder to
forgive yourself
yes and marijuana makes you feel like it
makes me
more uh compassionate makes me more
friendly it makes me
want to hug people gives me more of a
sense of community exactly it makes me
like people who i believe did something
wrong to me yeah you're like
[ __ ] okay my man yeah it's like
he doesn't mean it he's just all [ __ ]
up just like me yeah if i'm drunk i'm
gonna blow that bread
yeah oh god the the fighting thing
that that that to feed that that
experience
is it's a different experience and it's
it's
it's got to be so hard for a world
championship fighter of your caliber
to exist with like regular normal
boring life you know when you're
training and you you're ramping yourself
up for a big fight
and then you have that big fight and you
you know you knock out spanx in front of
the whole world and
you you you're walking around the ring
and you're on the cover of every
magazine
that the highs of that the
accomplishment the training and then the
competing itself is
the experience is so alien to most
people
that when you walk around with regular
folks in regular life
it's gotta it's gotta be hard to exist
no it's not it's just that um
you have to know who you can be at
certain times of your life no one knows
who they are because if you know if you
knew who you were right now you'd be
really limited
you know because life is about change
you're going to be told then five years
from now you'll be a different person
won't be this person
so we're gonna have to develop some kind
of emotional intelligence
and just learn the gr as time goes on
grasp
what's ever going on and just form with
it as a change you change with it
because it's very difficult
when times change to change with the
times right
and you have to be conscious of that and
the times is not
the people around you the time is the
development and time you have left on
this planet
that you have to develop who you are how
difficult is it to make that change
though to become a different person
other than a world championship fighter
like when you decided to stop
was it difficult well time will make you
that person time will
yeah time will make you that person what
is time i don't know
right but time has also made you that
person again now though
now now it's reignited now new time
has come and now you train it again
exactly but i think this is done
mostly for my health for my immortality
more than anything
subconsciously i think that's what
what's the reason why i did it just to
get healthy
yeah then this stuff goes on and this
and then i meet a doctor and say hey you
know you should do this and then
and you should try um stem cell mic you
never tried stem but this is what really
got me interested in this stuff i
thought i interviewed
which i like to do you as well on my
podcast
if you if you're licensed to do this
your content won't oh yeah for sure
so um i had the opportunity to
um talk to kitten shamrock
okay and so he came in and i looked at
him i said [ __ ] he look incredible what
the [ __ ] hey what are you doing right
now why you look like that
how's that happen and he said it was in
colombia and i said when give me i'm
going tomorrow
right but um i had some people nearby
that i happened to be introduced to and
they were on
um they're on the top are they really is
that that bio accelerator place down in
columbia is that what it does
i didn't go there is that where henry
cejudo went i have no idea who went
there i have no idea
that i knew it was in colombia and um i
met some other people who were um
yes on top of the game on that game with
this anti-age and all the stuff that's
going on with this alternative stuff
also and so um
i met these people and it was just
amazing stuff
so you're able to now train all these
days a week
you you have uh like how many months in
now
you you're solid since april yeah and
you attribute that mostly to all these
different alternative methods of uh
absolutely especially uh this gentleman
that we call his name is brad wrote we
call him the mechanic
the electrician that is and he and he
works through
these current forces and that was
electro muscular stimulation
is totally different within that family
but just totally
superior than that that's just so
antiquated compared to this stuff
you know so uh
you you were talking about your ability
to you're running in the morning and now
what's the afternoon's like what are you
doing in the afternoons
um that's when i'm training around one
o'clock i'm in the gym i'm doing the
training
um 2 30 i'm probably talking on the
phone
and flipping some deals making
arrangements probably to do other shows
the
commercial or some ads and just says
that [ __ ] yeah business stuff
and how did you get hooked up with
rafael cordero because for folks who
don't know he's
legendary trainer in mma he's from shoot
the box in brazil
he was one of the the top guys back when
uh shoot the box was the number one mma
camp in brazil where
anderson silva and van der ley silva
found this out later
but this is how this happened the two of
us met um
i said hey you know i like to hit the
mitts you know you think i hit the
mitchell somebody think you got somebody
right i get to miss i was getting ready
to go to freddy's gym
freddy roach yeah and then um
someone said they had um
raphael and i thought hey let me check
him out and
it was she was just perfect is he near
you does he live near you or something
he lives in
laguna i'm in newport uh
what is another laguna it's close enough
yeah yeah that's close
that's real close so
before the available pandemic but that's
what i mean we came before the pandemic
we were
in vague as we met i guess at the um one
of the ufc fights
and then i met him over here and i was
saying i want to hit the message and
that's how
we um got back together he's a great man
like a good person no the reason why
i kept not necessarily because he was
awesome with the myth because he brought
so much
peace and love and stuff to the whole
family the whole
camp his images and yeah
he's just awesome yeah he's got great
energy he's being loved
yes like in in the mma world and all by
all the people that he trains with
everyone loves
cordelia you can't find a person to say
a bad word about that man he's so
awesome
and he's a very good trainer and he's he
also was a guy
like i was that style that hot that
shoot box style
they were very aggressive and i was like
oh well that actually makes sense him
and you together yeah when we do drills
the drills are what's going on
we know when we hit in the midst there's
no use hey
hit the middle pop up pop it's booming
we're moving it's acting boom yeah
heart beating being heartbeating hard
breathing and we're just working at it
yeah i'm watching and i'm saying this is
it's interesting because he's doing he's
got you doing a lot of like
side to side and angles oh yeah listen i
do eight
eight rounds on the back and i do four
rounds with me and i'm moving oh whoo
you feel that that's that bag what was
that bag of that would that even really
work out
yeah you know he said was that really
even a workout what was that to warm me
up for this what was that about you
don't even know that existed after you
did the four five
so when you go from april when you first
started doing it again to now
how much better do you feel listen that
um
that was just a joke at the beginning
you know right now it's really
perking up it feels like real training
yeah
it does it's taking that deep
do you feel like you could train as hard
as you did back
when you were in your prime well listen
um you have a tape here don't you that
we could look at
is there a film did someone yeah do you
have a film of my tape of me hitting the
mids in my prime
and see me hitting the miss now i bet we
do i better
look at me somebody myself hit the
missing 88 let me hit the myth um from
last week and you tell me
no listen i'll tell you you look [ __ ]
fantastic that's what's interesting
wow that's me i said look at this yeah
it's just i had more endurance back
there than that but now
i'm catching up well that's what it's
interesting about it it's not like
watching an old fighter that has lost it
that's just trying to compete
it's like watching an old fighter regain
those old skills like you look great man
that's what's crazy about it i'm just
going to work on this and work often and
keep working on it and see where this
goes
it's so exciting i love it listen when i
announce
the listen this is um johnny ryan the
guy that works with us and arrows and
stuff
when we announced the fights he got um
we got in 2.5 billion hits
i'm serious i believe it i believe it no
this is going to be a huge fight
i mean this fight is probably going to
be one of the biggest fights of all time
in terms of pay-per-view in terms of
people buying it and watching it
and there it is a great video in terms
of helping people as well
of uh roy and you uh training together
there's a
compilation it looks like somebody's
speeding my god damn
my mother-in-law said they speed that up
and my wife said they said no i think
they
did not that's that's um the electrician
oh the uh the the umbrella electrical
muscular stimulation [ __ ]
yeah yeah no it doesn't look like it's
sped up it looks like you still have the
speed that's what it looks like that's
what's so exciting about it
with a king's mma shirt on yeah
so exciting it's so exciting man it
really is
i i'm i'm 100 into this
and i can't wait for the fight to go
down it's going to be november 18th now
right
um believe that 28th 28th 20th november
20th there was enough time for fans and
everybody and thanksgiving to be home
and they'd be able to view it
yeah for the holidays and just be able
to help more people
the more people that view it this is so
exciting man
no are you doing weight lifting are you
doing any swimming like what are the
kind of exercises
i did was when that shock commercial
that was the only thing i was gonna ask
you about that
stuff and um we're doing little weights
we get a lot of reps and just
doing a lot of so you have a strength
and conditioning coach
okay so he's doing yeah yeah brad rowe
i've known i've heard that name before
weightlifting champ change train
weightlifting champs and all that stuff
and um he's just an awesome person and
we just kicking butt
and how many days a week are you doing
strength conditioning along with your
running and then
monday to friday i think we do saturdays
too and i say hey i'm boy let's just go
saturday
wow how good does it feel to get back in
shape again man and to look great
hey it feels awesome but it's listen
there's nothing easy about it
you know getting in shape is easy not
easy it's just
it's continuous stuff it's it's
consistency
there it is
so how the [ __ ] did they talk you into
getting in the ocean with sharks what
was that all about
listen um i don't know how they did this
the money wasn't really that great and
stuff you know
and i'm sorry shark world you guys
underpaid me and um
they had me out there i was there and um
it was really interesting man it was
really interesting i'm just saying how
did these guys get me
in here yeah i was wondering the same
thing and this oh dana thought he was
doing me if i don't finally want mike to
fail
sonic might do a couple of games with
these guys and i'm saying thanks a lot
dan you really like me
dana really liked me i'm saying that
while dana really cares about me
he said forget the fight i want him if i
want to see mike go [ __ ] with some
sharks
yeah i would i would say fighting is
probably safer
yeah dana didn't want you to fight right
yeah but then he wants me to go with
sharks though
why didn't he want you to fight did you
talk to him about it no you see he has
never seen it until he seen it and watch
me
once he saw you then he changed his mind
yeah
once i think once someone sees the
dedication that you have that that
you're actually fit
you're actually moving fast and you
actually can compete at a very high
level
i just had to realize that um i'm not
gonna rush in there like that no more i
gotta move around gotta do it in a
different way because i tried to go in
the first time spawn and it was disaster
so i went in there
thinking using my head moving and things
went the way i wanted
how long in training was the first time
you sparred
first time 15 years first time you
started in 15 years
and how many months in the training was
that from from you started in april
so like when did you start really boxing
stuff box box and stuff
is when i did that stuff with um
the blind did the stuff with raphael
first time right but i'm being mean
first sparring first bar in rounds
yeah it was really weird and stuff but i
realized when i was getting hit boom
boom boom i hit a couple of times
i didn't go like what the [ __ ] am i
doing i said wait i belong here oh
it brought it back yeah i said i
belonged to it i got boom boom boom and
i got rocking i heard the ring and boom
as a woman i didn't panic i said oh i
belong here
wow that was long hair started moving
and start talking about whoa i belong
here
nice i never said what the [ __ ] am i
doing this [ __ ] is crazy it just never
happened
it never happened i was expecting that
you're expecting what the [ __ ] am i
doing [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
hey stop [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] i ain't
doing this [ __ ]
but um that's what i was expecting
really bad right i said whoa
boom boom boom boom uh then you felt it
and you readjusted it the first thing i
said
i i said whoa i belong here
nice how long did it take before you
started feeling comfortable sparring
the next time i spawned again really
yeah
so the next time you start again you
just could get back into the mindset of
what it's like
to be competing and moving with another
person yeah and
you can't go for the kill because you
don't know your body's not moving for
the kill now you gotta
have you have to develop the relation oh
this is gonna be interesting when you
hear this
and the fighter probably doesn't
understand that but as he gets older you
have to develop
reacquaint a relationship with your mind
and your body mm-hmm
your legs go here before your body's
ready to go with it
sometimes right you have to um they have
to sync up yeah that's the sync up now
you have to talk
hey before we win win before we leave
let's do it bing bing bing now
hey man let's move here let's move here
right i have to talk you lose that tenth
of a second
when you talk to yourself right you're
doing it instantly
so do you think eventually you'll get
back to automatic
well we're gonna see yeah i like that
yeah
yeah i'd like that too
it's exciting though man it's very
exciting to see you sparring again to
see all that
um but now when you're sparring are you
uh sparring technically are you sparring
hard like um
the first time i went back i tried to go
all out and i was disastrous
uh my body was it wasn't listening right
right and so i had like you said i had
to develop that relationship
and the second time i spoke that was
better that was so much better yeah
yeah i wasn't rushing and trying to hurt
nobody kill nobody that was just trying
to
get accomplished yeah just get working
yeah and how often they spawn in a week
um when we go back to spawn i like spawn
every day
really every day yeah the more you do it
the better it is
right the more your timing is the better
you feel what are your thoughts on like
some people think that you could spar
two months and you leave too much in the
gym because you get hit too much
in camp well that's the whole thing you
learn in camp not to get hit
that's the art of boxing learning not to
get hit in the fight and you have to do
that
but trying to get hit in the gym yeah go
seriously
and avoiding that and then it turns out
in the fight so you shouldn't be in the
gym
saying i've been hit too much because
you shouldn't get hit because that
should be the objective of
fighting not to get hit as much as you
believe you are
what do you say to a fighter that sees
themselves getting hit too much though
in sparring do you tell him to take some
time off or do you say
you know know what i say i try to teach
him how not to to avoid those punches
and if he doesn't i don't really want to
have much to do with somebody i don't
want to be involved with somebody
getting hit and they're getting hurt and
stuff like that well i know you were
doing a lot of uh
coaching of uh just even little small
sessions with different fighters and
yeah there's a bunch of stuff on the
internet
if you ever did you think about doing
that like in the future like no no no
not
at this moment it just takes a really
special position it takes a special
person to do that you got to be a mother
a father a psychiatrist
yeah a dietitian it's just so many hats
you have to wear
being a trainer a good trainer a true
trainer to yourself and your fighters
it's just a lot of hats
that's really overwhelming for me and my
personality
i totally can understand that but i
would also imagine that in your mind
there's some knowledge that i would love
to see passed on to other fighters
in a way like a trainer only a trainer
can do yeah i'm the kind of guy if you
want to learn from me you got to learn
from it
let me talk to you or something because
i'm not like us of course we'll go
because we never get tired answering
questions sometimes my son asked me so i
said why did you guys ask me because
that's the way i was with cuss
right you know but i'm not because would
never get he would love to answer all my
questions because the custom wanted the
perception that he knew everything you
should listen to him and take his advice
because he knew
everything yeah you know that's what
it's like if he was his friend you
always came to him for advice he always
wanted to invite
one to give his advice and let you know
that he was a superior thinker and that
you should come to him and
he'll settle your problems that's just
what he was you know do you think ever
think back on your life
like your life with cuss and just the
story the origin story
is almost like a movie it's almost not
crazy no no
let me tell you what happened man i'm in
spafit detention for boys
and muhammad ali they showed the movie
the greatest it's like 77 76 from 11
years
they played ali and then um ali walks in
and talked to the kids and i saw him and
i saw everybody going crazy i want to be
like him
and from there i go upstate new york
there's a guy that used to be a
professional boxer named bobby stewart
mr stewart taught me how to box and
eventually said i wanted to do so they
took me upstairs my custom auto
this is all in a couple of months since
i've seen that league
and now i'm training to be a boxer crazy
but it's and you were 13 right no i was
um
i would think i was 13 yeah look that's
like
it's like a movie it was no i knew i was
going to be successful
i knew everything was going to go right
there's no i knew it it was in my blood
i was on that kid but i say i want to be
like that guy and they just started
working
and it's such an amazing listen listen
not even
not even three or four months after i
saw ali
met him i'm in one place i had a fight
trying to stab guys i did with a pencil
or something i go from there
and i go over to this bad place elm with
this cottage that's where bobby stewart
because he's a fighter and he had to
take care of these all the staff they're
big strong man because they have to take
care of these
very interesting kids you know like um
homicidal kid these are kids wow
yeah and so um that's the job we're in
the while we're in the bag college to
lock up
college elmwood and so um we have the
bad remedies that's the crazy kid
college gets the lock down no one can
go outside like we they got to be
handcuffed when they leave the
cottage and stuff and so that's where
i've
i've i've gotten my tutelage that's
where i learned to go to school that's
why i've learned everything in this bad
boy place this place where all the bad
kids at
and since they had to have extreme kind
of
guards their security mr stewart was a
professional boxer
and he would teach the kids how to boxes
they behaved themselves and got on a
certain level
in which you can go back there in box
and guys were coming back
to the dome i was locked i was on the
level to go because i just got there so
they put me in the back to lock you up
too
they um they see what kind of person you
are so they'll put you in
the group and i see these guys coming
back with their eyes busted teeth
knocked out the ribs or
but they were happy they're laughing
about this yo he [ __ ] you up yo baby
you almost got him
and i said yo what's going on and what's
happening this year we're famous for
still with boxing mr stewart
and stuff and they're happy with them
bleeding the tooth knocked out there
but they were happy and it was
enthusiasm i said i wanted to do that
too but i wanted to be tough and so mrs
stewart that talked to me didn't want to
teach me
so i started cleaning and being real
nice kid to everybody because i wanted
to learn how to box
all the kids were happy and he started
teaching me how to box
it's crazy that you met cuss too because
out of all the people that you could
meet
no one was better at the psychological
oh i would never been the champ
if i wasn't from because um he put stuff
in my mind i started thinking about
myself being these people visualizing
myself
being i don't know grade of somebody
i've never done that in my life
i've never heard not even in the ghetto
somebody say this
like i said wow he's great like i'm
talking about like at home i said wow
he's incredible
why is he incredible i don't think that
incredible
why shouldn't you have that why should
he have that not you i've never heard
smith said it to me
but cuss was a master at the
psychological
master like you just you would hear him
talk about things just reading the
things that he's written
about about the psychology of fighting
he was the perfect guy for you it was
almost like the stars alive
that's what i'm talking about yeah it
really is
like a movie it really is like it all
lined up and plus
physically you were so unusual you were
so unusual so gifted i mean even when
you were right
i told him that he can't be able to be
too small
you know no way in the world he can't be
too short because he's too small he's
got the 225 to 30.
well obviously they were wrong big time
but it was also
you you you might have been short but
you
you had the best style and cuss
developed that with you
the best style to deal with the fact
that you were shorter the bobbin and the
weave in the constant pressure
exactly but i believe um style is
relevant i believe it's the the morale
behind the style
i think success in fighting in life is
about desire
and the will yeah how bad do you want it
they're worth dying for
that's his true greatness is the
willingness to die so this thing worth
the mindset that he instilled in you
and the way he gave you the tools in
order to think about things in a way
that that
that fueled that mindset yeah but that
doesn't do good in the real world though
it really is really disastrous in the
real world
right right now yeah that's true with
that too yeah
yeah isn't that crazy it's like the very
thing that made you
special could [ __ ] you in the real
the real world guys like that go to
prison they don't exist in the real
world
yeah take them out of there it's crazy
now they have to they have to remove
them from the real world those kind of
people like myself
isn't that what's crazy like that's
where the crazy adjustment has to come
in where you have to learn how to be
and that's where cannabis helped you a
lot too oh man forget it
i get it i get it but now you're not
smoking any weed getting ready for this
fight
do you miss it well i understand my the
discipline
of this stuff yeah what i don't like
about it that is just
that without cannabis i it doesn't
matter being i just get
mean yeah i don't like the mean stuff
like i don't like i might snap at my
wife and my kids that's what i don't
like right what uh right right well i
see the sparkle in your eye again
it's a little different right now than
the last time i was talking to you
there's a little more intensity going on
but it's also you're ramping up
yeah you know i'm just always um and
sometimes um
i get beside myself and i forget that um
i have to use i have to be grateful yeah
what i love what god did in general and
um
sometimes um i get caught up into my ego
right so it's just a struggle but i'm
working on it
i never worked on it before so that's
the start right right
i never could consider working by but
that is the thing right
what gets you to be a championship level
fighter can really [ __ ] you up and hold
on oh
i can't believe i'm so happy my wife is
still with me i'm just very grateful
because i miss useless
and stuff and i have to learn to do i
have to learn how to live life
yeah life i'm disastrous and living life
oh
[ __ ] joke i did it i would never
believe
you know using these nice words and i'm
conducting myself you come to my
nice house and you would say this guy is
just
uncool the uncouth neanderthal you know
so obvious
i used to listen to my wife people think
it's stupid i listen to this right so
she told me become
before i came in be kind and be nice to
evidence be kind and nice
because i don't eat most of the time i
want to eat afterwards and if i don't
eat enough she says she's going to get
angry can you please eat so she's
forcing me to eat this stuff for friday
goodness
and so i said okay i eat but um she's
right because of
time we've been married 11 years
well you got a good one then man you got
someone who balances you out
someone who understands you yeah i don't
know listen i was talking i said you
know sometimes
sometimes i think about um we're
together and this is going to be over
something we're going to die once one of
us is going to die before the other ones
and say i would not know what to do if
you died first
wow and i had to take care of these kids
because the whole life is me
and all my kids right her life is me
and not only our kids the two kids that
we have but huh
life is me and all my kids right
and um
i would just love her and marry her just
for that alone
no [ __ ] no passion no sex that alone
yeah yeah that's beautiful man
find someone who balances you out like
that absolutely
but that um what we were talking about
where
the very fire that gets you to be mike
tyson that turns you into this
destroyer inside the ring will
if you don't learn how to control it
we'll [ __ ] you up in every other aspect
for instance like after my one round
fights
some of them calls me lawsuit because
right after that i'm you think i'm calm
down you think after
30 seconds or 45 seconds hey he's cool
after one run everything's cool he's
happy it's over
it's still ringing yeah it's revving up
it's still wrapped it's not finished
it's not dead the energy's not dead
not the energy just that your jet the
energy of hurting somebody is continuing
to hit somebody it's revved up
right and so the first thing you hear
that indicates altercation it's not hey
what bro it's just off
and you have no control over it right
you have and it's almost like you're
insane like
why can't i stop this why is this
happening to me why am i in jail right
now
[Laughter]
and you're mike tyson so it's not like
anybody can tell you not to do it
or anybody can tell you to shut up or
calm down and you're not going to listen
to anybody you're the [ __ ] king of
the world
but it's crazy when the people in the
jail and prisoners know you real well
you know they're familiar with doing
when they see you they're not excited
now right yeah they get really familiar
with you
um jamie foxx is gonna play you in a
movie that's gonna be interesting that's
gonna be interesting it's wild
if anybody can do it jamie foxx can do
it that's a talented man
he's really good at what he's [ __ ]
talented he that guy could do anything
he's one of those dudes you listen to
him sing you hear him play music you see
him do stand-up comedy then you see him
act
like this [ __ ] guy can do anything
he's just one of those dudes
that can just lock in on something and
he can do anything yo listen when the
light is on you when um
when the when the universe puts the
light on you there's nothing stronger
than a person whose time has come
yeah it's all about the light man
all of us get it you mean i think the
homeless man on the corner the blind and
parallel paralyzed guy that's begging in
the cup
we all get that moment of shine we all
get it
feelings perform whatever it is we all
get it now when jamie is playing you
what does that feel
like i know michael j white played you
once yeah
did you talk to him about it i didn't
know him or anything i was in jail
when this guy was all that stuff do you
know michael john
i met him a few great guys he appears to
be very very nice guy
i've known him for a long time and very
respectful guy too
but was it weird watching someone play
you dig
no no no no it's just
that ego [ __ ] kicks in so i'm watching
it
and he and he had some good qualities
and he did some really good stuff that i
thought
um but the stuff that he did that
represented me i don't think people even
picked up on it
like what kind of stuff it's the way he
moved his head
yeah people don't know crack my neck all
the time yeah what was that about you're
always doing
no um what had happened when i had
fought
bone question smith he had hit me and
the next thing i know i don't know how
to quick in my i couldn't stop
my neck was messed up so i had to go in
um the chiropractor i don't know what
the heck
was wrong with it
did you ever have neck problems like
would you you need surgery yeah
you you remember when i used to do those
rolls on my head
yes the football yeah bridges
they destroy your neck yeah i would do
them this is the entry i would do them
for three minutes and stop a minute them
for three minutes so i do it for five or
six and
eight rounds and as time went on it just
beat me up in there
that gave you a crazy [ __ ] neck
though man your neck just 20 inches
your neck you just started your temples
and just go straight down
i mean for fighting you need a good neck
are you doing anything to strengthen
your neck
yes i have the weight stuff you ever use
the iron neck do you ever you know what
that is no
it's a halo i'll give you one i have one
in the back it's a halo
you put it on you pump it up it fits
around your head and then it's got a
bungee cord on it so you back up like
this the bungee cords 50 pounds
and then you do these and
because it doesn't do this with your
neck it doesn't put pressure on the
discs
so it doesn't move the discs in an
unnatural way with the weight
yeah because you can do all these
different exercises on it
but it doesn't ever bend your disc so it
strengthens the neck
without doing damage to your discs it's
a thumbs interesting yeah you know what
i have
i would love that yeah thank you i
really appreciate it i have um
what's the name i have a um a treadmill
that um
you have to put on some shorts first and
then you zip you it's like oh in the
water
no it's not water you put on some shorts
you zip the shirts with the plastic that
covers the machine
and you start running and then you can
run a fashion game won't feel anything
is it but it's not water inside no you
just run on the treadmill
it's on the plastic it's and it's zipped
up around you this thing right here
zero gravity treadmill is that that's
what it is yeah wow
how's that working that's pretty awesome
you don't feel anything then you take
the pencil if you feel a little sexy
pulling my foot to the floor
really yeah really cool so this way it
doesn't beat up your joints
yeah but listen this is what people
don't understand
yeah you have a machine it'll be a bit
when you're running outside
the higher running outside is almost
worth messing your joints up
really yeah then what the height you get
from running outside
what's the difference between the height
i do i do i don't run outside but
like what do you feel
man it's just um i can't even articulate
this
between being outside running and um
it's like night and day so looking
inside the house on the treatment on
being outside running
it's like night and day you can't even
compare the two is it because you're
you're
moving you're traveling distance is it
because you're breathing in the fresh
air like is the spiritual difference
[Music]
it's just the spiritualism running
hearing the birds hearing the
the whatever the animals run into
breaking the sticks and the weeds you
know he's conscious of everything
right it's real running as opposed to
just exercise on a machine
exactly yeah even if you have a
headphone on you're still conscious of
everything out there
now have you talked to jamie foxx yeah
well he's getting ready to do this i
talked to jamie is periodically
all the time we don't even talk about
the film really yeah we don't talk about
it
now he's getting bulked up too he's
getting jacked he looks huge
he wait till we finish when is this
supposed to take place
whenever he's ready i guess wow that's
wild
so when when he gets ready to do it is
he gonna hang out with you and try to
take on your mannerisms or
well he's known for quite a long time so
he knows my mannerism he's not gonna
if i if i died he can do me right right
pretty much you know so he wouldn't have
to be around me
do you want to help him you want to give
him any pointers whatever you want
whatever help and what um areas and what
direction you need me to help them in
yeah that's a it's a great capable of
doing it yeah if you're gonna have
someone play you i think he's the
perfect person
he's just good and there's other guys
too but he's just
he just knows three he has been there
you know it's hard to get a guy that's
just
20 years old and then we're going to
have him portrayed as a 25
and he just never get it right when
somebody understands the environment
that they lived in
at that particular time and they create
that environment again in their mind
once they
they're under the influence of that
person they're portraying
jamie's gonna get something knock it out
the park oh he'll knock it out the park
he understands that environment and that
chemistry he's going to
rein reconnect
now are you going to be a consultant on
this move or anything to make sure that
it's all legit
listen jamie will be around me it's
disgusting with me i'm sure
we have that taken care of as well but
you know we're just gonna
work this out the best way possible for
both of us i believe
now when is it supposed to follow you
when you're a young man or is it
supposed to be you
as a champion well we're not gonna talk
about that right now it's gonna be a
bunch of stuff but you just really dig
it
oh i'm gonna tell them some really
interesting stuff
so you're saying that the running
outside it's worth it
just for the spiritual difference it's
worth the beating up on the joints does
it
does it [ __ ] with your joints do you
have like knee problems or ankle
problems
these days hey i do but um
but the guys i work with uh they take
care of that right away
you know it's almost like it's like
i don't know it's like um
i don't know i want to say healing like
i'm 18 but it's almost like putting
super glue on your joints all right you
know like super glue wanna get stuck in
your finger
it is interesting what they can do today
like you could heal and recover
way better than you ever could before
there was no 54 year old men that looked
like
you when we were kids no no jacqueline
was the only one
yeah and even jacqueline i mean he was
kind of fit but he was just fit because
he was disciplined yeah
because he continued to exercise deep
into his mind what was all about yeah i
don't care how good you are on anything
you don't have discipline you ain't
nobody right
you're nothing about discipline because
you give up on the slightest struggle
without discipline 100
and um that has to be something that you
also learned from custody
i don't know what this one is i don't
know this one he told me discipline is
doing what you hate to do
but do it like you love it ah
doing what you hate to do but do it like
you love it
that's that is a great quote and if you
can do that you could be successful in
anything you know you normally are
you'd be the best janitor in the history
of janitors
yeah and i just use that for a
perspective not just putting those
janitors down
yeah you know the best of it i know what
you're saying
um when when you're when all is said and
done i would love it if someone
sat down with you and and made maybe a
book of all the things that cos
taught you now
no those things that cost told me and
nowadays would not be
cool you know what i don't know um
customers born in 1908.
in 1908 they had a different opinion of
people having opinions like women and
stuff like that
and it's cuss because
believing that he cares for the
downtrodden people
and this and that's for the blacks and
latinos and
irish people who are being a um
abused by the irish people of that time
which is crazy
um he really um
he really was that guy he was the guy
that fought for the people that
that didn't have um he wanted to fight
for them
he was just that guy he wanted to be
that person he wanted to be a person
that people looked up to and he was the
boss and stuff he was he just wanted to
be a people
and when i read his book and i found at
the bottom he was successful his whole
life
he was always the guy in the
neighborhood that people came through to
settle beasts and talk
things over with and loan people stuff
and help people out
and he liked being in that position of
being able to teach people something
what he believed was teaching them
something
but he knew so much about the human mind
well he well when he died this is very
interesting
we were dying in the camille there was
um
that i lived with him in camille and we
went out of the cleaning room and when i
saw in this room i saw all books about
psychiatry and the mind
and everything and mystic stuff and all
that stuff
and i said this is what he was really
about um
yeah he just like he believed his mystic
believer as well he believed in
zen and art of archery and all that he
had those books and he was just a
believer
and more than what we saw yeah you know
it was more than what we
could physically articulate going on
with us as human beings
are what we are called when you sit back
and
you think about your career and how
fortunate you were to run into that guy
i mean how much did that play a a part
in your mind like when you knocked out
trevor berbick
became the youngest ever heavyweight
champion when you're thinking about that
we
did you do you ever stop and think like
man how lucky am i that i ran into that
man
no no he said he summons me he summoned
you
whoa
makes sense i mean you think about a man
whose life work
involved psychiatry involved the mind
boxing hypnosis
training all these boxers floyd
patterson had all these great fighters
and then he wants one great one
before it's over and he's summoned no he
wants an animal
i'm an animal
he summoned you
what'd that feel like for you does it
make sense
no i believe what he told me yeah
it it i mean i don't know if i believe
you could summon someone
but god damn that seems like it's real
yeah
that seems like it's real i don't know i
think you could do whatever you believe
you can do
if you really believe it yeah well that
that was what i got out of all the
things that i read about you and him
together and
being able to talk to you about you and
him is that he
he gave you these tools to understand
the way your mind worked and you just
ran with them
um i'm an extreme kind of person yeah so
i get carried away
if your confidence is not a and um
a delusional perspective you have the
right confidence
yeah you get so amped up mike you even
even he's sitting here talking to you
about these things i could see it in you
you get amped up even just talking about
achieving things
talking about success talking about the
mind you know i could see it inside of
you you get very fired up about these
things
yeah um i have to be serious about
anything
i want to accomplish yeah that
intensity is what made you special i
mean that
that i mean you i can't have people it's
the first time i had my wife and kids
around me
normally this can't happen i have to be
away from them
for camp yeah yeah no i can tell man
you're different right now
than the last time i saw you i could
tell you're ramping up for this fight
yeah it's just it's just what it is i
don't i don't know if i like being who i
am it's just
it's who i am are you planning on doing
this and then seeing whether or not
you're cool with it after it's over
and then maybe going back to the way you
work or you just want to do it
you just want to do it yeah let's just
do it only think about that for now and
then let all the chips fall where they
may after it's over
i just do it i just want to do it i like
doing it i don't think it'll be
disastrous or nothing this is gonna be
awesome and we're gonna
do it i'm so glad you're doing it man
there's a lot of people that had
negative opinions about it and i was
like listen no this is interesting
okay think about it hold on well you're
not that old
i'm 53 i'm a year younger yeah but
listen the fact is like
when they said um they can't get people
on the moon because
they didn't want to believe it because
it's like me they don't want to believe
it
but what they're going to say what
happens
i think there's a difference in today
than there was in 20 years ago when you
were dealing with a 54 year old person
when
when you talk about recovery when sport
science what they know about how to make
the body work
what they know about training and
conditioning people are just different
now
yeah but they always have to do you
could be in so many steroids and pills
or whatever they got health growth and
all that stuff
but listen you can be the best physical
shaping right if you don't go out there
with a good mental perspective is gonna
turn out disastrous
yeah if you're not mentally prepared
yeah it's gonna be disastrous but that's
the thing that i'm liking about talking
to you you seem very mentally prepared
you're ramped up mike yeah i don't know
if i am it's just that um
this is who i am i guess um i don't know
i like fighting well
that's that's why you were so [ __ ]
great at it and that's what's so
exciting about this is that you're back
into that mindset again
i guess so yeah i try to control it
because i have to know how people at
home
have to just level my personality down
for
that's the problem right the problem is
yeah yeah turn once you turn the switch
on it just to get to keep
you know normally when i'm in this mode
i only want a slave i don't want a
family member
i had to cut stuff down to me i don't
have to be
from a humanity perspective you get in
the conquerors mindset
it's just that i think everything should
go my way while i'm going through this
process
yeah you know i think no should be a
foreign language for this next two
months
for what i need to prepare for what i
need to prepare for everything should go
your way
yeah from my perspective yeah for me no
from me knowing me
preparing for what i need to prepare for
yeah that's an alien
thought process for most people they
don't understand like to be
mike tyson to be who you were when you
were at the top you have to think like
that
i don't know i think anyone think i
think you think like that
you think like that i mean to fight i
think the fight is the most extreme
version of that though
for you to prepare for the for let's say
who you were going to just say you had
joe biden in here for you to prepare for
that
that's going to be very interesting
right you're not gonna come at him like
you came out somebody that you know that
you're comfortable with
you're gonna look at it from a different
perspective let me hit him from this
part and see where he's going because
he's gonna look at you
just some small sports jock yeah so
you're gonna say yeah i'm gonna surprise
him and come in from this direction
that's just how we thank the competitive
we don't want nobody to think
what we are we wanted them to have a
little bit of
figuring out process with what we are if
i had joe biden in here i think i'd get
really high before i talk to him oh that
would be beautiful i think he would be
high too
you can't tell me he's not a high guy he
looks like he's a high guy
he's going to be high he definitely it
seems like he's on something
yeah but i would get i would get really
high before i talk to a dude like that
uh just to try to feel you know how
sometimes when you're real high you can
feel
you feel energy from people good or bad
you feel it
i mean you got the mushroom you got them
pegged yeah whoa
baby yeah yeah yeah when you're hunting
mushrooms you see who they really are
behind the screen
yes my wife don't like me he's not much
to see you on streams again huh don't
come in here with a damn shrimp
shrooms and dmt don't mess with shrooms
what's that
that's a no-no for me at the house don't
bring that [ __ ] home yeah
that's funny man yeah when you if just
even micro dosing if you micro dose
mushrooms you're around people you
especially if someone's lying to you
especially they're pretending they're
something they're not
if i've done mushrooms alone before i
used to do like a bag the day i was
and then when i stopped for like um
three months and i said let me just do a
load
i'm looking to tell them bang
i'm god and you guys are just here for
my entertainment
[Laughter]
they just wasn't telling me that friends
is cool and then start sounding
whoa it sounds good and then boom i hit
you
i know some dudes who train on it they
like to train on mushrooms listen when i
took some mushrooms and i did the bike
for two hours but it was like
it was just like i was in the zone
but breathing heavy you know i could
hear my breathing i'm like what the
wow i'm going to try and breathe you're
going to die holy [ __ ]
i don't stop real living i'm thinking
i'm dead because that's what mushrooms
do it makes you believe you're dead
yeah gives you that feeling of [ __ ]
like boom it's just
yeah i'm i'm i'm living dead feeling
that your soul is separate from your
physical body
listen why can't they listen stop it's
like
if no it's like you're in this room
right i'm in this room
and well you said that blew my mind used
to i'm in the room
and all the room is like it could be
like
the whole room this whole room is like
covered in like a
kind of like shaded visible and i'm just
covered in the whole and it's just me
and everything the whole world is
outside of me yeah
and it's like i'm gone and everything is
just my entertainment i'm just looking
in
and no one sees me and i'm what it's
just oh man forget it
i gotta understand hey baby baby baby
even though i've been hiding this
this stuff for my baby baby i took some
shrooms i'm not feeling good baby
i'm sorry i'm just not feeling good i'm
feeling [ __ ] i'm not feeling good what
does your wife say when you do that
he said i told you not to eat that [ __ ]
stop doing it
i'd learn things when i do them though
too i learned things absolutely
yeah and i said see baby because when i
do learn i tell my wife she said this is
true
i said see the show no the shrimps
mama's the show
it gives me that enlightenment but it's
also
once i do shrooms sometimes i know why i
have to stop doing the show because i
start doing it too much
and then i lose concept of time mmm
i might have been um like just say me
and my wife's in the car
we drop off the kid to a class that she
goes
once every week we drop her off then we
come back to the house
and i just say hey where's milan
we just dropped off mike and i lost that
um concept i
time yeah yeah it makes regular life
seem
like trivial so you things like time
yeah
they don't doesn't mean anything anymore
it's a problem
yeah if you have to keep appointments oh
no i'm not gonna make that
um and if you go there and if you your
body just
the shrimp tell you hey you shouldn't
really be here this is not worth our
time this is not what we're
um this is not what we're vibing on to
reach the higher level
this becomes disastrous so you know this
guy becomes the enemy now he's stopping
my enlighten me now
yeah yeah yeah yeah shrooms uh
it's uh i think it should i think there
should be clinics
some of them in the country they
still a schedule one drug unfortunately
in this country but i think there should
be clinics where professionals
listen have you heard about the um the
white cobra the white cobra yeah
oh he's a great psychedelic too it's
another psychedelic oh the lizard's tail
the the centipede yeah yeah
no the total question of the toe the
shoulder p what else
the jelly fish i believe this one and
they have
they have a quite a few animals that
possess
that psychedelic chemicals yeah well
we're being [ __ ] in this country
because they keep that [ __ ] from us and
they make it illegal
and so many people have learned great
things about themselves through
mushrooms and through all kinds of
different psychedelics
especially micro doses they learned how
to stop us from drinking they
gave us a rule to stop us from drinking
by taking shrooms and lsd
yeah it stops people from smoking
cigarettes i just think um
we abused them i think they've been
using them since the beginning of time
yes people like us we abuse them yeah
but people abuse everything they abuse
cheeseburgers and alcohol
it does you should be able to take
whatever you want as a grown man
and there's the the fact that this
country keeps it from us and
and keeps it illegal it's [ __ ] up
because it could benefit so many people
i think
why would benefit the better because
they wanted the benefit the people who
was hiding
from us are the ones that's in benefit i
think the people that are hiding from us
they're protected pharmaceutical
companies well listen i don't know who
they are but i know they're somebody
yeah yeah well there's a lot of factors
there's a lot of factors but
for me personally and for a lot of
people that i know uh
they've gained great benefits from
psychedelics
they think about this world we live in
what do you think about how do they
make this how did what is the origin of
it yeah
yeah the world is a strange place and
stranger right now because of kovid and
because everyone's locked down
society's kind of [ __ ] up and i just
think we as human beings what we are who
we are whatever we exist to be we're
[ __ ] germs and we're the cause of
everything that happens to us like
i just always think that people let out
the vibe like we're we're viruses
we're fungus that's what we are fungus
if we look at us from
um you know the perspective of
consciousness what do we do we get sick
we get other people sick and we die
yeah have you ever heard of terence
mckenna you know what terence mckenna is
no tell me about parents
terence mckenna was a brilliant
ethnobotanist he was a guy that worked
with plants and he was into psychedelics
and he had a theory
called the stoned ape theory and he
believed that human beings became human
beings because of psychedelics
he thinks that we developed into human
beings when
lower hominids like ancient man was
experimenting with mushrooms that could
be interesting
so i think well let me not think that
let me say i
saw um i saw documentaries
and from the documentaries it appears to
be that um the world was created off of
drugs
someone's taking some drugs and then
reaching that
that believed to be um divine
intervention from god and um
this is how the world was discovered if
you ever
do some research in the history of drugs
yeah i've definitely done some research
in the history of drugs oh so i'm
sure you understand yeah well drugs and
human beings
for sure it accelerates creativity right
it gives people ideas
but the idea behind psilocybin is a
bunch of ideas one of them is that it
actually
can make people think about things like
language and that language could have
come about from people making these
connections from psilocybin it also
makes people a little bit more creative
it makes people horny increases visual
acuity
maybe i'm compassionate makes them
compassionate would
would bond them in terms of community
and also it's better for them
as well and if you think about it for
long periods of time if that became a
part of the human diet
and it would make sense that that would
make physically because
the diet has always been abused our diet
is being abused now because that's why
we have to obese
sure now but and that's what happens
with all these
um extreme drugs and alternative drugs
we abuse them we take them too much we
smoke too much wheat
well you know we spoke too much we we
smoke too many cigarettes we just do too
much of
everything yeah we do abuse [ __ ] yeah
why do you think that is why do you
think people
do you think but don't you think that
that same abuse that same
like that's also what makes people great
at things too
because that same almost the same
mindset that allows someone to abuse
drugs or abuse gambling and become
obsessed with pornography
also is the same mindset if channeled
the right way
that allows someone to become obsessed
with boxing what what what's what
prevents
them from doing the right thing from the
wrong thing with the same feeling
emotional intelligence yes a lot
the majority of the world don't even
possess the world the world is not even
50 years old
right so um this is going to be a
struggle for the next 100 years that's
good until we get that
yeah that's gonna have to be um our main
objective to develop that
yeah in order to succeed as human beings
yeah that's no truer words have ever
been said that's what it is it's
emotional intelligence because listen
our feelings are enslaved by our
emotions and our emotions are enslaved
by our feelings
and sometimes we sort of placate those
emotions by
drowning it in food or in booze or in
gambling or sex or
anything that can continue and then we
turn that
into memories yeah and then we become
enslaved to our memories
and never stops right we that's who we
are
we are an alcoholic we allow ourselves
to become that yes
we can stop from coming that just like
um
we learned um alcoholics anonymous yeah
so we can learn from that
so that's why they learned from that so
now it's not hopeless anymore right
that's why it's so hard for people
because they have a memory of all the
things they've done
that's wrong and they do it all the time
and that becomes who they think they are
until they start changing the picture
right it's all about changing the
channel you know right change that
channel in life
well that's what's so exciting about you
with this new chapter of your life
you've just
completely changed who you are you went
from
pot smoking mike tyson who's running
tyson ranch who's this real nice guy to
hang around with
doing hot boxing with mike tyson fun to
be with
everything's great and all of a sudden
you shift right back into mike tyson
the murderer again well it's just that
um
as i said earlier today if we knew who
we were
we'd be very limited you know
we don't know who we are we don't know
you don't know what you might do
tomorrow when you wake up it's true
you might are you married yeah well
listen you might
get married again you know you might go
crazy yeah he might take out a new job
no yeah well that's one of the exciting
things about life right i mean this has
to be exciting time for you
to make this big switch yeah think about
that too
but i think about a lot i think about a
lot like you know i'm 54 and then
um i'm not going to be here much longer
when i go in my love and see my wife and
kids again the
friends that i loved all my life my
mother go see them again i started
thinking about that
you know you know you know when we think
about it i was
disguised this guy's book what to say
every
one beat away from him and turn our
internal journey some guy sent me that
book
and i said wow this is pretty cool
because it's true we're only one
heartbeat away from dying yeah and going
on that long ride of
not knowing yeah a feeling because
that's when i was on the toe
dmt is all about feeling yeah the feel
makes the reality
how much did that change your
perspective on life when you had those
experiences
it got me in shape it got me this this
is what it had me do
as soon as i did it the first time i did
it it just blew my mind then i did it
again and hey you better get in shape
let's get in shape what the [ __ ] wrong
with you
[Laughter]
yeah listen and um that's like i did
i told you hey you're [ __ ] up
especially when you think about it i'm
not the guy you have to say hey mike man
you know you gained a few pounds let's
kind of work it out man you can do it
yeah you big fat dumb [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together look at you big fat mother
you're a fat
lazy [ __ ] that motivates me you
need to hear that
and you need to tell yourself yeah no
anybody the right person needs to tell
it to me too who the [ __ ] gonna say
that dude
they do hey hey hey
oh i was i listened i was i was
somewhere around freddie
i went somewhere to do something then i
saw
one of freddie roach's trainers irish
guy european guy
and he knew me for years because i used
to work with he said what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you look at you man
this is not [ __ ] right look at that
mike what the [ __ ] are you
doing and wow i felt this big brother
and he said around a bunch of people but
he said you know this is not
right this is not right so much i said
[ __ ]
he's right and um i got right
yeah some people would call that fat
shaming
but i think fat jamie works for me works
for me too if i got family i always want
somebody yeah somebody's not yelling at
me
and i found out he that's and he thought
that i was a fat [ __ ] he
wouldn't tell me i wouldn't be a friend
of him i wouldn't be cool with him no
more
if he's not telling me your mic man this
is not right man at least let me know
i might not want to do but let me know
yeah that i'm not looking good [ __ ]
ain't right
yeah you know because the guy ain't
gonna tell you he's hanging around let
you stay
eating and [ __ ] hanging around
drinking yeah that's the enemy man yeah
that's the enemy
so you do the dmt trip and then you have
it in your head like hey i gotta get in
shape
absolutely absolutely like sometimes you
say like
body shaming doesn't hurt people it
hurts it hurts some people
to me it makes me hey man let me it
helps me that's the kind i'm not that
guy
the only way it hurts people is if you
don't listen if someone says you're fat
and then it hurts your feelings but you
don't work out
then it hurts you but if someone says
you're fat and it hurts your feelings
and you say i'm going to use this as a
motivator to get back in shape exactly
then it helps you
exactly fat shaming is only bad if you
don't stop yeah
i never looked at it as fat shame like
when that's what you said like who's
gonna say it to mike
like i don't respect that guy yeah the
guy that thinks like that i'm not gonna
tell him
oh i'm that's my enemy right he's not
helping you he's my enemy right
right he's my enemy so the dmt trip
opened your eyes to that
absolutely yeah but that's not something
you want to do while you're in camp
you know um i did it 16 times 17 16
times yeah
never regret doing it and that would be
good
doing it i think everybody should do it
it's just um
not everybody but everybody wants it
yeah yeah for everybody not everybody
who
everybody who needs it should do it i
should say that yeah because some people
believe this is all this is the real
world out here
yeah they really believe this is reality
isn't that interesting like once you do
it you realize that that world is so
more vivid
than this world and um we're gonna be in
that world longer than we gotta be in
this world
how about that let me hurry up and die
get this [ __ ] all the way all right
yeah that's probably true i don't know
what it is but it's probably true
but this listen this is what happened
you do this toe stuff or any of those um
interesting narcotics
you have a different opinion about dying
and the fear of dying
yeah you know you say you start to think
hey maybe i'm living too long
you know [ __ ] well maybe that's just
another
existence that's that's what what made
me think like maybe this is always there
and maybe this life that we have that
this temporary life that we're clinging
on to that's so important i don't know
why
why why is it even the guy that he's why
nobody wants to really
stick on to the fact that after he dies
over why nobody want to hold on to that
yeah then saying well there's something
more it's than really being confident
with saying
hey there's something else after this
and that's from scammers
from dying early or what you know why do
people stick with that is that the
smooth
is that the soften our ride to their
eternal life of darkness or what
it might be i mean we don't know until
we die right yeah
but everybody thinks the people that
think that it's just over
when you die it's over you the world
goes darkness and then that's it
that might be right or it might be that
you go to that place where you go when
you smoke dmt
it might be that that might be you don't
remember when you were born do you
you know you're not going to remember
when you died yeah i think when we're
born again if we're born again i could
remember the life we had never remember
this [ __ ]
oh i've always said everybody's scared
to die but no one's scared to sleep
you know sleep no some people are yeah
some people are afraid to sleep
you know they get their moments where
sometimes you say wait i might not wake
up this morning because
you you hear and you know people that
just go to sleep having a nice time with
you didn't do any drugs and they just
don't
wake up that's true too but the thing
about sleep is
you're pretty confident you're going to
come back so you're willing to shut off
it's okay
but no one wants to shut off forever but
um listen the belief that you're going
to come back is magnificent
yeah the belief to know that we're going
to wake up in the morning imagine we
went into life like that
yeah with that belief yeah
and you think life is just temporary
and then when it's over you're going to
go to an even more magnificent place we
say life what life
when we that's not life is not over
right when we leave this place
right it's another form of life we
haven't experienced yet
right even if it's the black life where
it's just all darkness
it's a part of life that we have to
embrace in some kind of form or fashion
well that's the weird thing about the
toad right is that there's no visions
but the but the feeling's so intense you
see yeah right
you're feeling so intense even makeup or
whatever you see it from
that's why feeling is so important we
just don't even understand the
feelings the eye we just don't
understand they they even lie to us
right our eyes lie to us
i remember the first thing i felt is so
insignificant
like you're just a part of everything
you're part of the whole universe
and instead of looking at yourself as a
center of the universe when i did it i
it just made me realize like no you're
part of this
infinite thing and you're such a small
part
everyone is such a small part the
universe itself is what's big and you're
just
a piece of it we're all just feeding
each other yeah we're all just feeding
each other our blood is just running
through each other's feet through the
holes the dirt the mud
everything the water the ocean the air
we're just all feeding each other
yeah the bugs there's more listen um
there's more stars in there in the space
than there are grains of sand
in the desert yeah imagine that it's
ridiculous
what do you think about aliens mike i
think we're aliens you think so i think
we're descendants of aliens
yeah yeah that's the only thing i could
come if you can't explain
if you can only tell me about adam and
eve i'm gonna go with the aliens
hmm if that's what you hit me with adam
and eve yeah i'm gonna go with these
alien guys
well there's a lot of people that
believe that we're the product of aliens
that aliens came down and
did some experience experiments with
lower hominids and did
some accelerated genetic experiments and
created people
well listen um aliens
listen when when certain tribes the
people i'm not saying saying
um um caucasians when they came to
africa even before that when people came
to other people
the first time they seen them they were
aliens yeah first time um
an asian man saw a caucasian man that
was an alien a black man saw asian man a
white man that was an alien yep
um maybe they want aliens but that's
what they thought they were they were
just a tribe of people
that encountered them and perhaps they
were getting extinct they were dying and
they had to um
breathe through the the lower whatever
you were saying
lord hermitage and maybe that this is
us because they had certain um as you
may know because i know you know you do
these kind of researches
they already discovered there was um
there were different forms of species
that that's working down to us that they
came from us
and now we're at the degree of i guess
where the human species divide
yeah there was a bunch of different
kinds of humans yeah yeah there was many
many different kinds of humans
and before they were here millions of
years
before millions of years after we um
were erectus after we walked they always
been here
it was very rare that you could find a
a human life that didn't wasn't a rectus
they could find a skeleton of one
that walked in all fours the oldest
person they found
is 4 million 4.4 million years old
lucy i believe it is 4.4 million years
old is nothing
it's nothing in terms of people people
were erected then people were walking on
both feet then
yeah you know for me for years
four million years ago so they never
found i don't believe they ever found
the
skeleton of a human that wasn't a rectus
that's one of the the things about life
is that life is so short
as well if everything goes well you live
100 years but that is nothing
in in terms of the the life of the
planet you know how long it took them to
build
the great wall of china thousands of
years two billion two thousand years
yeah two thousand years yeah
can you imagine that and that's nothing
2000 years is
less than what christ has been around
christ is young
you're not a young crisis you're not
young here in terms of the world yeah
yeah yeah that's how
how bad they wanted to keep the mongols
out they built the [ __ ] wall it took
them thousands of years
you ever read about genghis khan listen
um
his real name is team ajin yeah and he
let me tell you what happened he's like
13 when he died around 13 what fourteen
and he
his real reign was like in the 12s and
the early 1300s
and first of all he came from he's real
poor his mother and father they all came
they got beat up they took it out
he had a woman then they took his wife
but he got friendly with a real bad
mother
a real uh he was a criminal but he was
the baddest from all he was so bad
and he loved um teemogen he just became
you know
some guy he'd see a guy and they said
one guy was he was really weak at the
time
and this other gang had took his wife
and he and the feminist guy was making
llama raid and stuff
and he was just saying what is wrong the
guy really loved him he said what is
wrong he said these people
took my wife and he said don't worry i
got many away what are you worrying
about that one way but i really love
that because he really loved her
and so the guy said listen i'm gonna
help you get your wife back but don't
ever tell nobody that we raided this
city because of a woman okay and so he
went back and the guy got his wife back
and so the guy allowed teamagen to be
number two because he loved him so much
but he got jealous because the men
started favoring
genghis because genghis would let them
raid everything and said keep it all
he wouldn't take not keep it or let the
men have it all and they all started
looking up to him and following him and
then the other guy got jealous
and eventually jenga had to kill him but
he said he wanted genghis and wanted to
but he said you have to kill me
and so king is killing but you want to
go when he said you're not going to
spill any blood so he crushed them
in the rocks if he wants big no blood no
cuts or nothing like that
but that was his best friend and after
he died that's how genghis had the
reputation
so you followed them you you pay
attention to them you you
read a bunch of [ __ ] i named my dog
after his favorite wife paley
oh wow so i know you've been into that
kind of [ __ ] like alexander the great
yeah
all the all the different conquerors
guys pippin
charlemagne clovis
now is this stuff that you just studied
because you wanted to study conquerors
that just interest you
i wanted to study that mindset
you know and um i found that the
greatest conqueror is
they ever lived um
the farmers you know farmers
sheepherders
somebody that we wouldn't think that's
important and stuff and then
as they became great through that they
may have gave birth to great children
who were born with greatness like
alexander the great and stuff like
philip the macedonian
that whole bloodline of alexander they
were all kings but they were very small
and insignificant
until um it was always one alexander
before him that was
pretty great and fought against the
persians but eventually they lost
and they pretty much kissed the
persian's ass you know i mean the
persians put them in a position
of power until um philip of phillip
macedonia came
who had the nickname aka philip the
barbarian
and he wanted to go across and enslave
all the persians and everybody after
that
the world and alexander the great mother
who was a really interesting woman
um
i'm trying to say albanian maybe and
they had a different kind of um
study and worship and stuff back then so
he got caught up in that
his family didn't like her for that but
um
she arranged for she arranged for
alexander's father i think to be killed
for alexander to have the power then her
kick says
the power she could lead to her kids
while he was on campaigns
right and um
when he was on these campaigns now that
his father was going he just
conquered everything but when he ran
into the afghani people
he fell in love with them he wanted to
breed with him he wanted to create a new
race of afghan he is madly fell in love
with him
and that's pretty much why his his
family is not saying but the
greeks went um what they went mountain
mutiny on him because they were jealous
that they were giving
big positions to the um the persians
no afghanistan he loved him he even
quotes afghanistan the most beautiful
people of the world god must have loved
them more than anybody
he made them beautiful he really fell in
love with them when did you start
getting really into like conquerors when
you started 15.
you're 15. yeah what what introduced you
to it um i was at the table eating with
custom
a friend of mine named craig what said a
statement which
was wrong but it sounds really good to
make me investigate
he said alexander the great at his time
was like six five so at six five three
hundred years before christ
that was a giant which was wrong he was
very small
the arm was too big for him he's really
small guy
he wasn't big at all and so
just that alone him saying that got you
interesting yeah i want him after he was
the monks he's a massive guy but i found
that he's just a small man
average guy you know he's not a mac
monster at all
not a big man at all but you got
interested in the the mindset of the
conquerors
listen this is what i want to know
why would one person think that he could
[ __ ] own the whole world one
person why would he have that mind who
would think like that
right why would a man person why would
that's not a [ __ ] person that's just
something
when your egos just got so out of whack
where you just
can't think rational how do you think
like that and you're a nice person
it was a guy before him a couple hundred
years before him named
cyrus the great he was just he was a
conqueror but he was a conqueror for
liberty
he wanted to conquer all slaves and let
them go conquer all the slave masters
let them go
he got killed for that too but can you
maybe that sounds
that sounds cool too right that's good
that's a good thing but listen
think about it who the [ __ ] is he to
take somebody else's property take
somebody else's stuff because he believe
is wrong which it probably is wrong i
think it's wrong but who the [ __ ] is he
right who is this guy to take others
just to conquer you you don't bother
nobody but this is what they did back
there
now you're killing everybody back then
it was really legal it's almost in the
bibles and
the books it's not i won't say it but
it's in books slavery it's in the books
in the religious books that we need
slaves and he did this
and this guy's gonna say hey no more
slaves
he's 500 b.c so he's going to say no
more slaves
no more slavery is wrong out through the
whole world so he wants to conquer the
world and free of
slaves wow so that's just a different
mindset yeah
the different kinds of mindsets that
these conquerors have but who doesn't
who he thinks he is who the hell is he
he has this little town over here how
he's going to call for the whole world
his town is right here
well forget his town his country is
right here
yeah you know and he don't even hear him
and even conquer this country there now
he's going to conquer the world and
liberate free to make freedom what kind
of
no that's nothing if that's not somebody
on drugs you don't you tell me
no you tell me now be honest that's not
somebody's high you tell me
it could be coke no [ __ ] it's something
right this is the at 500 bc this is
slavery is what it is this is
the way of the world no i'm going to
free all the slaves
that's pretty crazy like everybody
what did you get out of like reading
about their mindset like
studying temujin studying alexander the
great like what did you get out of
reading their
about their mindsets um
i found out that the greatest ones the
best
the most prolific ones
were all mama's boys really yes
afraid of their mother wow napoleon
alexander
you know i mean wow
genghis khan too yeah really yeah
what do you what do you think that is
huh what do you think that's all about
highly respect their mother i'm not
thinking they're
um i think their mothers were the first
especially alexander the great
i think she was the first stage mother i
think there was some before her too
you know because cleopatra was one
that's just what they were at the end of
that they were they were wanting to lead
through their sons
or their daughters or something like
that oh okay
like like that parent that takes their
kids to athletic events and
screams and cheers and pumps them up and
no no no no no it's the parent who
whose child word is law and i want to be
able to have that
word um okay do you get that yeah
my son is the king right this country a
couple of countries
but i want i want i want my thought to
be in his mind come out of his mouth do
you think the parents
convinced the child that they were that
special that they should run the world
some of them do but as some kids get
older like ivan the great having the
terrible
they get older and then they realize
these people weren't right to me and i
and they started killing his
sponsors of the people that would rip
his step parents and stuff
you know some of the kings did it too
you know so when when you were studying
this
when you were coming up as a boxer and
you're studying all these conquerors
you were trying to understand their
mindsets yeah and you were trying to
apply that to your own life
pretty much yeah did you get anything
out of it yeah
yeah yeah what did what did you get like
what how did it apply to your own life
well at the end of the day to all ask
god for forgiveness hmm
all of them
so when you're reading all these books
about all these conquerors when you're a
young man
and you're on your way to becoming the
youngest ever heavyweight champion
and you you're trying to take on the
mindset of the conquerors and you find
out they all ask god for forgiveness
yes how did that affect you that was
pretty cool
because by that i learned greatness was
the willingness to die by you know
doing researching on these particular
individuals and that's what they were
willing to do for greatness
um and you you know you heard about
achilles and stuff
he what does he want a short life of um
of greatness than us a long life of
obscurity
yeah he took the short life and that's
what alexander did
when you when you study these people and
you uh
you you take that conqueror's mindset
did you get anything out of that did you
do you apply that into your own
your own pursuit as a champion
absolutely because you have to listen
alexander the great was 32 and he
conquered the known world
yeah in 10 years
and so thinking about that as a as a
young man absolutely
i want um i want my preeminence to rival
the time that
you know in the stands of time it's not
rain with it
i think everybody should want that that
are competitive
in the art of um what do you say
immortality yeah and i search for it
that's what he wanted he wanted he
wanted immortality that's what he wanted
he wanted to be known since you know
till the end of time
did you ever think that maybe you were
born in the wrong time that maybe if you
were born in the times of alexander the
great you would also be a conqueror
no i am a conqueror now because i have
conquered myself
and my demons you know not because i'm
at that time i'm never born until i'm
born in the right time
most of them couldn't conquer their
demons that's why they asked for
forgiveness from god
all of them because just like um
the gentleman um that discovered um
um alcohol is anonymous you know
he um he inspired maybe he maybe he had
a problem with alcohol at the end
but how many people have he inspired
yeah that is so much bigger than him
succeeding or not with his problem
you know what's interesting about him is
uh he
was interested in lsd bill wilson yeah
yeah that was a big thing of his
that's what that's what instructed him
to have the program yeah to develop the
program
yeah when you're talking about they all
would seek forgiveness from god that's
so interesting to me that you turn to
cannabis and cannabis
will allowed you to forgive yourself
yeah i'm listen the reason why they
asked for forgiveness for god this is
why this is interesting that you said
that
it's because they believed they were god
and they had at the end of the day
realize and check themselves that
they're not yeah they're not god
and then they've done horrific things oh
yeah at the end of his life he was so
forgiving and giving everything away and
so sorry for everything he didn't know
how to forgive himself either he didn't
know how
how do you do that when you think you go
how do you forgive yourself so at the
end of the day he said look the man who
conquered the world
died with nothing in his hand he gave
everything away he had no swords or
nothing
he was so freaked out about dying being
the rich guy
and stuff and having so much property
and having the world like he
possessed because he had the world it's
this gentleman that he
well you genius forgot the guy that they
named sloth after
the animal sloth eugenius i don't know
but he was like he's considered a
homeless bum
nowadays today he would be called obama
homeless guy or whatever
and alexander been watching him this is
how keen he is he's watched this guy for
years
and he said listen before he became king
of greece he's watched this guy
this is when he was in the camera and he
said hey listen
i watch you and i have everything and
i'm unhappy and you don't have nothing
so
what can i do to you to make you happy
you know what he said
nobody had the balls to say he said
first of all you can be kind enough to
move out the way of the son
and then allowed me to enjoy my day
and he couldn't conceive of somebody to
turn him down for riches and stuff he
couldn't conceive of it it just blew his
mind
he was so blown away he couldn't even
kill a guy for disrespecting him he was
just blown away
he said this i have everything and i
didn't realize he wasn't happy he had it
all
he's the king he didn't even know where
he was getting ready to go he didn't
mean to be king of the world but he
can't
reason he's just not happy and he has
everything
so he thinks by conquering the world
it's going to make him happy and he did
and he what happened
he turned into a drug wow
imagine that it's crazy he ran that's
what he
experienced with new drugs he listened
when um when you went on a campaign know
what i thought i thought when you went
on the campaign
the movies lie they said you go on a
campaign that's just about
300 gladiators or whatever 10 000 so you
know they bring their whole family with
them
it's like a party their wives their kids
everything they got the um surveyors
with them um house builders are with
them
the people who deal with um agriculture
for that time everything's with the wine
even for they could test everything when
they
conquered coffman you know what
conquering is
we think that's glorious conquering this
glory and why because now it is
conqueror is robbing rape and illegally
taking somebody else's goods and
enslaving them that's
conquering that's not good people
all the people we like we say these guys
this guy he conquered this he conquered
that
they hurt people they did it for greed
they didn't do it for
we're going to help our people they did
it to take things because they
could now when you were coming up as a
fighter
and you were reading all these things
about conquerors
you you were fueling your mind in that
way and you were also
studying a lot of fights you studied all
the old school champions are you doing
that
now in this resurgence like are you
studying
no because i think i know everything
about the moment i've did the research
no i was a kid so i started reading to
that i started going to the other leg
level so i go from the level of these
guys that are fighters
the gladiators all those guys so i go to
from them to the generals
and from the generals to the gods
and that uh but that occupied a lot of
your time when you were training right
absolutely
yeah and did but that what are you doing
now like that
there's anything that's similar that you
do like when you were watching those old
school tapes if you were watching like
jack dempsey or or harry greb or any of
these old school fighters
that was there was something about that
that was providing you with the
inspiration you were you were you were
learning from it but it was also you're
getting yourself into this mindset yeah
because i know if i was like d that cuz
would tell you the more you
the more you win the more you beat these
guys the more the people who
applaud them the more you enjoy doing it
um and um i wanted the people i wanted
people to um
have the same feeling towards me that i
had towards
the older fighters of yesterday yeah
so i was madly in love with fighters i
was just now just
and if i met a fighter hard
let's get this kid out of there we just
bug him to death let me carry you back
and help you this guy do this
just [ __ ] you know you think they
were going to like you for being hey get
this [ __ ] kid away
yeah yeah yeah yeah carry a bag can help
you with this
but you're not you don't um study films
like that anymore now
periodically but you know what i do
sometimes because they have youtube i
look at youtube and they have fight let
me check
out let me check him out let me check
also i might see some rave robs and some
willy pep stuff
yeah i have one let me check this out
lomachenko is a wild guy to watch isn't
he
he's really um he's really
nice to watch he's really interesting
right yeah i like watching the footwork
is so exciting
i just like doing that he's like
watching a lot of people hate on him but
you know that's how it is
you know he got the light when yeah
that's the light they got after you
yep who else gets you excited that's uh
fighting today they got a couple of guys
haney
good the guy she's good good the other
little guy from baltimore is good
it's quite a few and it has a couple of
guys um
that's under them that's pretty good
that's in that that's gonna come up and
be really good with them else spence is
really good
terence crawford terence crawford is
good there's a bunch of good fighters
out
there the little guy ryan garcia yes
he's the hot [ __ ]
right yeah crazy [ __ ]
i love he's
but they're talking [ __ ] yeah and i'm
saying i'm an insecurity that's amazing
i paint a puncher right in the face they
might think i'm a punk let them do that
to me
and that these guys are friends that
look so cool yeah
what do you think of the heavyweight
division nowadays all right
joshua there's all everybody's good for
that time i don't think they're bums or
anything like that but
everybody's i want to have something
negative to say about somebody right you
know
this is their time they're the best of
their time you got to give them
that credit you can't compete with guys
for the past our guys are coming up now
this is just their time
this is what it is right now this is
what it is right now this time
we're going to judge it from right here
what do you think about it so it's an
interesting group at the very top of the
heap right tyson fury deontay wilder
anthony joshua i mean it's a it's an
interesting group
at the at the top level right now no
it's not interesting they're all
exciting fighters yeah they're all going
to make a great deal of money they
need to fight each other yeah stop
bullshitting just all fight each other
fight each other a couple of times
yeah and then when this stuff is over
you guys could say hey listen
we did it our way right you know this is
what happened to me i'm such an
egomaniac i fell in love that's like
difficult laughing i'm the king forever
i'm always gonna be the king this is the
way it is
[ __ ] you i never think about tomorrow
nothing this is now i'm the king
just kiss my [ __ ] ring this and that
and the fact that i just thought i never
list this is what i didn't listen to
cuz say hey yes you always really
don't take this person i took fighting
personal because they don't take it
personally it's not
personal right i took it personal and
the ego makes me take it personal
so when he said don't take it personal
what did he mean by that don't
allow it to stop you from living your
life in a happy perspective
i lost the fight don't commit suicide
start drinking and doing cocaine and
[ __ ]
stuff [ __ ] girls without rubbish that
you don't know you met him 10 minutes
ago
don't do these things okay don't do
these things when you lose the fight
like
okay don't do anything you lose the
fight
you shake the guy's hand you go to the
gym you work harder prepare for the
fight
you pay you win the fight you don't win
the fight you prepare harder wait for
the next fight
you win the fight you don't get the
fight fight some other guys you win the
fight then fight them again
the name of the game that you stay busy
you keep working
how much different would things would
have been if costed a lot yes really
different
but it wasn't meant for that to be yeah
i had to refill i had to figure this
stuff out he couldn't protect me my
whole life
right you know yeah i've always wondered
i always wondered what would have been
different if he had stayed alive
because i mean he had he guided you in
such an amazing way
you know and you because he was just
listening
because he's just a hard guy to get
along with
cust was just enemy prone if he didn't
have an enemy he would create one
really one of those guys he loved
fighting he wants to fight if he doesn't
fight he doesn't want to lift
wow wants to fight he needs to have
somebody to fight
if he doesn't have somebody to fight
he'll find somebody to fight he must
have loved having you
as a pupil oh well i listened to
everything he said
i listened to him i was around him he
loved people to listen to him
and i took him say everything he said i
would do if he told me to kill somebody
that would kill somebody
you know anything he said i did it
did you think about him even today while
you're training
absolutely after i think about it all
the time
you know what i mean i think about them
all the time i wish she could sell my
kids
i wish she could have probably seen you
know what i did how i did and how my
kids turned out and now yeah you know
went to great schools and they
did cool things and they're just kids
and they really
they just really um sweet kids that
really don't understand life yet and
maybe
because they didn't have a father like i
had
and things are different than it was for
me yeah you don't want your kids
fighting
no no i did that that's what i did if i
didn't have to
yeah i remember you were talking about
your son uh hitting pads
and like him possibly fighting like man
you don't want to find an animal like me
there's people that don't have nothing
to lose and all the whole dreams about
if i beat this guy
i'll get that new bike yeah i might get
this car that's how it was because
if you win this tournament i'm gonna get
you this you win the summer i'll get you
your gold teeth
i will try to save my money off my gold
teeth and if i win this tournament
you win this tournament i'll get your
gold teeth
everything everything you always um
dangle the carrot yeah
you win
well listen mike i'm very excited about
your comeback i am as well i'm very
happy that you're doing it i'm happy you
look fantastic it was
real cool to be able to sit down and
talk to you about it and i'm 100
enthusiastic about it
i think so i look forward to seeing you
there because i'm sure some people will
be there
and we'll we're excited no i would try
to be there live i would love to be
there live
if it's possible if i could be there i'm
just going to love this [ __ ]
i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited
looking at you being fit and how
enthusiastic you are and uh i wish you
nothing but the best brother thank you
thank you thank you very much
staying with you man you had so much
success in doing it thank you broadcast
here man thanks brother
[ __ ] who would you want to interview
i don't i i don't i don't have anybody
in my head that i need to interview
you want to do bill clinton and none of
those guys i'd like to do bill clinton
i'd like to get high with bill clinton
oh [ __ ]
you know he has a brother named roger
such an awesome guy
yeah yeah i saw roger before my friend's
house and roger is just a beautiful
person
yeah i i but i don't need to you know i
would
if he wanted to do it i would do it but
i don't need to i like talking to
everybody man
yeah i like talking to my friends i like
telling you i like talking to anybody
you know that i should know what i did a
couple of times i talked to some
homeless people and they're very
interesting
yeah i think uh sometimes i think in the
end i'm gonna be i'mma overwhelmed them
intellectually and i get
humbled sometimes well a lot of humble
people are really smart they just [ __ ]
up their
whatever part of their head that that
couldn't keep it together what i mean
yeah i think i know you know this guy is
out and dirty and
teeth fell out and this guy start
enlightening me
and then he has to tell me to leave
because i'm stuck there
tell me get out of here are you enjoying
doing hot boxing
hey listen um i haven't done it in a
while since this stuff
since you started training yeah and um
that's cool too that's cool too
i don't think i'm a good host while i'm
under this kind of duration
i understand yeah no i like i said i
could see the intensity you're you're
ramped up right now
you're a different person than last time
i talked to you yeah i guess
but excited that's exciting this on my
wife for she shouldn't have told me to
get on that
treadmill really she don't believe you
predicted it man you predicted it on
this show
you said i don't want to reignite my ego
yeah and you did it
but i'm excited that you did it i'm
excited i can't wait for november 28th
man i just want you
man listen oh god man i've been working
wait let me show you when i
leave here then okay all right show me
yeah thank you
thank you brother thank you very much
sir thank you bye everybody
let me show you something i want to show
you